[Music]
[Applause]
thank you xander
how about this huh can you believe it i
mean i haven't been in a room like this
in a long time it is uh kind
and courageous of you to all show up and
i hope we make a wonderful night out of
it there's a lot of people in this film
because you know infrastructure and
resources are all about people the
landscape is all about people and one of
the reasons that this was the hardest
tricking thing i've ever done
uh was not only
that usually i have 80 to 120 source
reels this time at over a thousand but
also the history of california uh when
you even of course it's true in san
francisco but when you fan out it's a
complex history it's a violent history
it's a difficult
history it's a history of extraction a
history of taking the images i hope are
meaningful as well as beautiful i hope
they're serious as well as funny there's
a lot of really beautiful
funny footage in here
most of the time i had fun putting this
together i'm not sure that
megan had fun putting up with me
but uh i hope you like it and i want to
remind you
every screening of lost landscapes is
unique because you are the soundtrack
you i'm asking you to make the
soundtrack to those of you who haven't
been here before to ask questions to
identify people places events
things to engage in spirited dialogue
with the people around you or the whole
auditorium if you like
you're free to
take photographs to tweet to use social
media just don't shine your phone and
anybody else's eyes
and maybe turn off your ringer but have
fun make some noise and
i'm so glad you're here
thank you
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
um
i can't read
[Applause]
thank you
mario
[Applause]
yes
i had to begin with a road trip
and each road trip in a lot of ways i
don't know i've started to
think about them as a reenactment of
manifest destiny maybe
this was a couple by the way
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
carlos
rican hill
cleared for the bridge but the bridge
isn't there yet
people complained about the high rises
even then
brand new coit tower
fourth point
the last original shoreline
twin peaks
where's the trees on sutro
there's the castro for when we get back
uh this is a mixture of 1939 and 1955.
this is the 70s of course
[Applause]
off we go
crossover drive
lincoln way
notice there's a little more of the
great highway back then
guerrero
there's a mask flying around
here we are
[Applause]
and these folks somewhere somehow back
in the 30s are reenacting that
moment of california and you notice the
film is decayed into little gold flecks
don't know
and from the able scanning hand of david
we glove is this beautiful shot of
market street in 64.
[Applause]
see ksan radio and tv on the right
1970.
many of you remember how long market
street was torn up
it would be twice as long today probably
right
[Music]
okay
pony express 100th anniversary
and the future
[Music]
so for years i've been hoping to find
footage of the general strike and it
started to happen
this is uh
probably a few days before bloody
thursday when these men killed two
workers
at the market and admission in stewart
um but here they are performing really
for the newsreel cameras because you'll
see
in a moment there's a newsreel
microphone
from fox or pathe or paramount
[Music]
the scene here is san francisco harbor
the ship has just arrived from baltimore
through the panama canal
bringing in its cargo the six reels of
submarine telephone cable that we see
being transferred to a waiting barge
the end of the long journey from eastern
factories near for the final resting
place of these cable circuits is to be
the floor of san francisco bay
in fact these are the actual circuits
that were planned to serve the
artificial island that was made to rise
from these historic waters as a home for
the golden gate international exposition
and after serving the crowds thronging
this appealing panorama of foreign
domestic attractions these same circuits
will be part of a great new cable artery
this artery will join the others already
winding beneath the surface of the bay
to bring the voice of america to this
busy port on our western shore
there's an interesting engineering story
in this sequence of pictures
but i see in them another in a special
significance and that is the
extraordinary skill and technique that
is mobilized in this modern day to
combat a small but deadly peril to set
circuits as these a single drop of water
yes
it is of vital importance to prevent the
entry of a single drop but if one drop
can ever soak in another and another and
another until the electrical
transmission of speech is impossible
such drama
we head east
this is the late 30s
what's up
[Music]
thanks
the supply chain was interesting back
then too
morning just like a day at pralinger
archives
west oakland cleared for quote-unquote
urban renewal you'll note that
recognize the east shore
and this is brooks island closed to the
public just across from um the ford
plant in richmond and these kids are
sort of symbolically
columbusing it
you can go there but only as part of a
special tour it's a wildlife preserve a
beautiful place
this is from a 1955 film about
developing contra costa county and i
hope they weren't
they didn't have designs on the island
[Music]
pretty natural
december 1940 just a year before pearl
harbor richmond was a contented
industrial community of 23 000 people
its long waterfront tidelands and mud
flats on the eastern shore of san
francisco bay was punctuated by
embryonic harbor development
[Music]
the temple of richmond was that of any
simple and conservative american town
only the straggling traveler and an
occasional train stopped this community
[Music]
then it happened
tens of thousands
some for profit some for patriotism some
to avenge a wartime loss
from each state in the union and almost
every hamlet in the nation these 20th
century pioneers converged on san
francisco bay
many came to find a new life to clutch
at an exciting adventure but primarily
every last individual wanted to help win
a war
various kinds of people from every creed
every nationality every race
all ages people from myriad walks of
life the socialite professor housewife
the actor musician bank clerk school
teacher the lawyer
less than two percent had seen a
shipyard or even a ship
in two years time the original payroll
of four thousand at yard one had
skyrocketed to 93 000 in the combined
richmond yards
the newcomer became a member of the
shipyard family by signing at the
employment office
he was recorded as a home front worker
and secured his union membership and
clearance
he was fingerprinted and photographed
for the permanent record and for his
band
[Music]
he could authorize a payroll deduction
for the purchase of warbond
at another window he was introduced to
the benefits of the permanente health
plan
while the six first aid stations in the
yards administered to all industrial
needs health plan members for 50 cents
per week received non-industrial
attention and complete health protection
highs i could go to the field hospital
for full diagnosis and treatment or to
the larger permanently foundation
hospital in oakland
91 of the employees subscribed making it
the largest voluntary health plan in
america shift changes created peak
traffic loads every means of conveyance
had to be set up
bus lines were extended to the shipyards
from all bay region communities
90 cars from new york city's abandoned
elevated railway were imported to apply
the 12 miles of the new electric
railroad between richmond and oakland
direct fairies served san francisco
residents on every ship
still of necessity the majority used
automobiles
parking and road facilities were
expanded because of gasoline and tire
shortages ride bureaus in each yard
assisted in carpool operations
those needing rides those providing them
cleared through these bureaus here also
they received their supplemental gas
rations
richmond shipbuilders topped the nation
in the share the ride principle averaged
more than four riders per car
[Music]
early lack of store facilities was
overcome through the establishment of
large supermarkets stock to provide for
every household need these crowded each
other along war-created thoroughfares
cafeterias coffee shops and fountains
mushroomed all over the new population
centers dispensing nutrition for
shipbuilding energy
in two years little richmond of 23 000
had become a bustling metropolis of 130
000
so this is port chicago
a few days after the big munitions
explosion
after that a number of black men working
unloading explosives refused to work i
guess they were in the navy and were
charged with mutiny and court martial
and uh
didn't get off the hook i think until
the 80s or the 90s i'm not sure that the
charges have ever
really been dropped
but this is is right after this this
munitions ship exploded and
looks like a bit of shell shock in town
uh does anybody know i mean i think it
it it was the the force was felt up to
15 miles away yeah it was like a small
nuke
yeah
it's like the third largest explosion
man-made that's non-nutrition
like in beirut last year
and this is in town not that close to
the naval weapons station
near again near there
there is a national park site there
okay
aranda was restricted
that is
when it was built
the placid
hills of contra
costa diablo
this is the patriarch of a japanese
family
and who was just walking up the stairs
there farmers in the central valley
and um thanks to lloyd molina and his
family
his family members
[Music]
i like to think that it's sort of a
symbolic
of the state capital
us50 now 580.
[Music]
water is the very lifeblood of
california's richest industry
agriculture
the lack of water for irrigation and
city water systems is the state's
greatest problem
the federal government recognizing the
urgency of this problem and the
importance to the nation of its solution
has built great dams like shasta hoover
davis and parker
but these are only part of a master plan
for water conservation for california
and the west
the freyant dam stores the cold waters
of the san joaquin at the base of the
high sierra
waters which had diverted and sent south
through a man-made river to parched but
fertile areas in fresno tulare and kern
counties where eventually a half million
new acres will be brought under
cultivation
[Music]
to replace the diverted waters of the
san joaquin the world's largest pumping
plant will force the waters of the
sacramento stored 300 miles to the north
by shasta dam
uphill 200 feet through giant aqueducts
from here it will flow 120 miles south
through another man-made river to
complete the great exchange of waters
between two rivers
[Music]
us the work of man is dramatically
balancing the unequal distribution of
land and water which nature has imposed
on california's central valley assuring
its future as a land of great promise
[Music]
speaking of water
we're in los angeles
[Laughter]
cool
the moist western slopes of the high
snow-capped sierras furnish water for
irrigation when needed in the great
valley
although there generally is good
rainfall
and
shot somewhere in kern county in 1947
is the lettuce harvest
[Music]
and what of the money earned by the
braceros is it all as some people claim
drained out of this country
hardly
look at the braceros when they come here
it is obvious they need a great many
things like clothes for instance
where do they spend their money
as a local merchant put it
as a matter of fact they spend a great
deal of their money right here
they buy clothing and other domestic
items such as transistor radios luggage
home furnishings items that aren't
readily available back home
take a look at the braceros when they
come into this country and again when
they leave
they have brand new shirts pants shoes
all items bought right here locally
let's look at this in a little different
angle
uh the stoop labor situation being what
it is i don't see how the local farmers
can get along without braceros without
this source of labor many farmers are
going to be unable to make a profit
and we sure don't want this to happen
because the farmer is still our best
customer
yes with the domestic supply of farm
labor being inadequate brusseros are a
must but some people say to the farmer
well make the pay high enough and you'll
pull in all the domestic labor you need
the fact is
that farm wages have gone up steadily
for many years
but we still don't have enough seasonal
domestic labor willing to do this kind
of work
conclusion
unless we have braceros to fill the gap
many stoop labor crops will be forced
out of american agriculture the
consequences
much of our food processing industries
output would be replaced by imports
these jobs now held by americans would
be taken by workers in other lands and
our plants and equipment would be slowed
down or shut down
that was the program to import workers
from mexico
who endured conditions like this for
example
[Music]
so a few years ago
megan was invited to uh to look at a
house that had been abandoned by his
family who had passed in seacliff and
found a box of film shot by a physician
an epidemiologist who is investigating
the cause of valley fever and in 3839 he
took his eight millimeter camera to kern
county
and made these pictures um this is the
territory that you see in grapes of
wrath and these are the people
in grapes of wrath
except these are the real ones
there's about i don't know 60 or 70
minutes of this footage and it's
it's rather amazing it was shot around
arvin
and also around um
uh i'll remember in a in a second um
valley fever hit
certain groups especially hard workers
of color were vulnerable to it
and it was transmitted spores by the
wind it's very windy there
say it again
[Music]
and shafter that's what i wanted to say
this is one of the camps that is seen in
grapes of wrath the other is weed patch
further south near arvin
california
uh
and an unidentified strike
[Applause]
this is more of dr smith's footage this
was when the valley
uh
hosted flowers before pesticides
altered its ability to grow anything
naturally
and of course the oil fields
his last shot
[Music]
and you know oil is a very charismatic
photographic subject
and these are various home movies
plus some feature film outtakes about
california oil
this is in southern california and
this i think is in venice
what's up
and those of you who know
venice will know speedway
this is speedway
what year
you know late 40s very early probably
about 48 49 it has a i think it's an
outtake from a noir film
i'm going to say 48
and the canals 1939
and the tar pits
and uh
latino los angeles
from about 1936-37
and about 10 years later a wedding
guys
[Music]
union station uh
very
months after it was built in 39
and this is rare footage of chavez
ravine the area that was destroyed
the community that was
was
torn down to build dodgers stadium
and this is
a home for elderly people
los fijitos
in the neighborhood
run by actually a white
doctor
well known in the community and then
there's also i just found
and david we have transferred a very
unusual general shot of the neighborhood
we're hoping to find more
history
[Music]
[Music]
the strength of california's industries
lies in the great financial houses of
the west
in their boardrooms along montgomery
street in san francisco
and in the stock exchange on spring
street in los angeles
decisions are made daily that influence
the future of california and the entire
pacific world
the nation's most overtaxed
communication system struggles
frantically to keep up with the demands
of this new growing industrial empire
and at the same time add service for
thousands of new homes every day
public transportation systems too are
seriously outgrown
more than four million cars are roaring
over streets and highways built for only
half a million
los angles the city of magnificent
distances
tackled the problem with typical
hollywood disregard for cost or effort
and slashed boldly through residential
and business areas to construct urgently
needed speedways
the state highway construction program
is staggering in its scope requiring an
expenditure of 75 million dollars a year
for the next 10 years
and this is footage shot mostly by
noah larda that we have courtesy of
ruthen butler beautiful footage of the
la freeways and the four level
interchange
many people photographed the four-level
interchange it was something i think
where there was a lot of pride and
perhaps almost a sense of
a landmark a center in a city that's
sometimes described as lacking a center
it'd be interesting it's a great feature
film project the four-level interchange
and some of this is shot from the
observation deck at the top of
los angeles city hall which is open on
weekdays
this is 58 or 59
long before the clean air act
peace
[Music]
the rail yards in the foreground la city
hall in the background and some gorgeous
footage of hollywood
these are made for backgrounds in
feature films
uh
and the
la city radio station i believe this was
on mount lee
these are home movies shot
while on the set of a jerry lewis movie
some of you may have seen that
disorderly orderly
this is in studio city you can look it
up that's actually well known
these are cans of high sea juice
and thanks to leslie iora we have um
films of her
family um
after they left san francisco where they
ran a laundry and some other businesses
they moved to hollywood and opened up a
nursery
before they were incarcerated
and
this is part of
quite a lot of footage actually that was
shot to exchange with their relatives in
japan
there was a two-way exchange of 16
millimeter home movies
this is near western avenue in l.a
an undated clip
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a recent discovery shot in
redlands california promo film for the
marketeer
geared to the needs of women i think
so to speak
uh
[Applause]
uh
filling out their cards
we've been trying to collect footage
from east los angeles and so far just a
little bit
sometimes a little hard to identify
we don't know anything about this family
unfortunately
and business street in east l.a can
anybody identify this
and um courtesy of brandon castro uh
footage of his uncle who was in the
brown berets
and this is the chicano moratorium
kind of behind the scenes uh footage
this was in 1970
and
it was
remarkable
demonstration of anti-war activity and
it's the toll that the vietnam war took
on communities of color
and
police fired indiscriminately into a bar
and killed a respected
chicano journalist
and
it's
an event that has had many
reverberations
in the last 50 years
the brown berets many of you may know
were grouped not unlike the panthers
the black panther is a community group
that
provided service and mutual aid
within
latinx communities at the time
and they're pictured here
i you know i'm saying here that
political activity is part of the
infrastructure of california and i hope
you agree
and here's um
mr castro and some round berets
occupying catalina
which was a symbolic occupation they
were initially welcomed
uh the the the tourist bureau decided to
welcome them to kind of you know blunt
the impact of this action
uh but after a while they became a
little bit of uh
trouble see here's the county sheriff's
keeping an eye on them
um and that's the i think it's the pasta
flag
and the flag of mexico of course and um
and uh and then they did their best to
get rid of them after the initial sort
of honeymoon
and these are from eight millimeter
films that
brandon castro has
kindly let us scan
and a lot of family material as well
[Music]
[Music]
i think these papers have something to
do with this car
and a special event in castro's life
i was born there
really
so
and i love the tom hayden sticker
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a a japanese american family we
don't know their name and this is
somebody who took on into a plane and
flew over los angeles in 1946 terminal
island san pedro
long beach area look at all these
military ships probably shouldn't have
photographed them from the air
anybody recognize that
so spruce goose howard hughes wooden
plane in long beach
where it sat for many years until it
moved up to oregon
liberty ship quite possibly built in
richmond
another pass
made of wood
the jones family lived in long beach and
shot some beautiful home movies um and
here they're at lax
flying somewhere i don't know where
in around 1954.
uh
and this is just a stock shot don't know
where it is it's a beautiful shot i
think it fosters certain illusions but
it's also an amazing image of sprawl
she's an actor
anybody know where this is
i think it's towards the desert this is
real estate development in
desert hot springs in the 50s
attracting trying to attract people from
the
la basin to buy
unimproved stretches of desert
some of these towns succeeded some of
them didn't
this is of course completely built up
now
[Music]
um
and further east
[Music]
you have to go to wikipedia to read the
history of
zizzix the old plank road
huh
uh somewhere in los angeles preparing
for new houses
and you'll recognize this those of you
who commute to santa cruz this is
pacifica
this is my commute so okay so originally
this was like eight minutes long and i
had to cut it down to 40 seconds
half moon bay before it was all built up
intersection of one and 92.
[Music]
we're on the way to santa cruz
russell sprouts probably or artichokes
keep that story moving
and this is mostly still here
santa cruz boardwalk the
casino
privately owned
trailer
yeah this is santa cruz the natural
bridge
bring your cats to the beach
[Music]
when the santa cruz campus opened in
1965
it already had a past
a hundred years before it had been a
pioneers ranch
now there are 600 students
most of them are freshmen and most of
them live in trailers
most of them also are members of the
campuses first oxford style cottage
cowell college named for the founder of
the ranch
[Music]
[Applause]
powell and the second college stevenson
are almost complete
and in the future santa cruz will have
more colleges and many more students
but already the corporate atmosphere
which college living encourages is
becoming a reality
[Music]
i've never made so many you know even
though there's not much romantic
interest i've never made such close
friends
i think you know that the intimate kind
of living situation forces you into this
kind of thing and then the bad things
are like you absolutely can't get away
you know i i just so long for a room of
my own i mean there's just definitely no
privacy
i don't know somehow time manages to get
taken out but i'm not quite sure how
i've always tried to figure this out i
never could oh there there are always
people to just mess around with i
remember at first you and kathy are
saying something about well there's
never any dates right you never go on a
date around here no you know and then
you laugh but it doesn't matter i don't
know maybe
definitions of dates you just don't call
anything a date really yeah yeah
i must say i like it
[Music]
[Music]
and here's a
motorcycle club somewhere in california
sometime i'm thinking late 40s
love to hear from somebody who knows
this history
[Music]
yes
uh
one form of the nature culture interface
in the grove that's been
threatened by recent fires and i don't
think that we know yet we haven't been
told what happened
the life of the lumberjack attracts
hearty men
men who are not afraid of work
whether is still work and danger for the
men who fell the big trees of redwood
pine and tamarack
mechanical improvements however have
taken away some of the backbreaking part
today modern trucks and tractors get the
giant logs from forest to mill
several billion board feet of lumber
come from the mills of the far western
states each year
and various
communities in northern california
some old growth
she has just fed the crew stake for
their hard work and we don't know what
town this is yet but this is um kind of
amazing footage of the mill
and the workers doing the work
is
this is a home movie
i imagine that it's you know shot by
that
somebody that owns or runs that place
and again we don't know
this man's tribal affiliation we don't
know where this is yet but i hope we
find out
my mind
home movies of these landmarks of civil
engineering and human
changes on the land
water and water power
and one of pg e's plants i've spared you
the other 19 that are in this film
and i don't know where this is either
but um
looks like it's electrified isn't it no
yes jay any ideas
um i drove across uh shasta dam last
week
uh and um of course the road's a little
wider now
and
kind of looks the same except that
there's no water anymore
it's about 20 to 25 capacity
uh
water power the backbone of industry is
inexhaustible in california it needs
only to be harnessed
[Music]
work is in progress and private and
federal projects all over the state in
an attempt to meet the demands for power
for this and future generations
the penn stocks of the government shasta
dam send the waters of the sacramento
river through giant dynamos capable of
producing enough power for not one but
several major cities
san francisco engineers added a new lake
to the map in the heart of yosemite when
they built hetch hetchy dam to supply
their city with water and power and
thirsty los angles reached up
175 miles in the high sierra to take the
entire owens river water supply
these are outtakes from sort of a how-to
film
shot close to ontario california in the
desert
huh
[Music]
good idea for a date
they've made a claim
atomic energy makes an important debut
on the west coast as a giant boiling
water reactor near pleasanton nears
completion the huge capsule which will
contain still another steel building
will house the radioactive metals which
will turn water into steam which will
furnish 5 000 kilowatts of electricity
to the surrounding area the 10 million
dollar project is undertaken by private
capital in cooperation with the atomic
energy commission and it is one of many
which will dot the nation in the near
future
student film made for the city of los
angeles
these pigs are waiting for their dinner
here it comes at last
like healthy pigs everywhere they're
always hungry
[Music]
these pigs are fed the scraps of food
that people don't eat
they live in clean pans with shade and
running water and every week a
government agent inspects them to make
sure that they're healthy and well fed
each pen opens into a concrete feeding
alley
[Music]
thousands of pigs like these grow fat on
food that would otherwise be wasted
food we separate and save for them at
home
[Music]
but a tin can or a piece of glass isn't
good to eat that's why we separate our
refuse
this broken piggy bank shouldn't be here
but here
[Music]
our crew collects bottles and tin cans
in a different kind of truck
the truck is full lake covered with
canvas
[Music]
so
[Music]
some bottles like these are set aside
they'll be returned to manufacturers
who'll sterilize them and use them again
this job takes sharp eyes and close
attention
the rest of the glass is sorted into two
large bins
one for colored glass
the other for clear glass
[Music]
toys are also saved
[Music]
this mountain of glass is glass that you
have thrown away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after the glass is broken and washed
these men sort through it to remove
corks and bottle caps
[Music]
[Applause]
clean broken glass is called cullet it's
melted down and used to make new bottles
there's some colored in all ordinary
glass
so it goes bottles broken glass cullet
and new bottles again
[Music]
disneyland
back on the east shore freeway
and this is this film promoting a
wise development in contra costa county
that was highway 24.
downtown lafayette
somebody has just
left
the city and moved into the suburbs
there was sprawl
this is somewhere around san jose
a lookout spotting a fire quickly
determines its direction and contacts
the rangers office
here a dispatcher with similar
information from other lookouts or
reports from air patrols or citizens
determines the fire's exact position
by radio or telephone men and equipment
from the nearest fire suppression crew
station are dispatched to the fire
by striking fast and striking hard 95
percent of the fires fought each year
are controlled before they have reached
15 acres in size
but sometimes often during periods of
extremely hot weather and high winds a
fire will spread too rapidly for control
by the initial attack forces
with action developing on many fronts
the fire boss must direct his forces
over a large area under different
conditions of terrain and forest cover
when necessary he uses aircraft to scout
the fire
a trained observer provides him with a
steady flow of information concerning
the spread of the fire
the best use of manpower and equipment
is accomplished through constant
air-to-ground communication and by
coordinating work of widely separated
forces by radio
the protection and management of the
wildlands is a personal concern to every
citizen of california each has a stake
in them
those people who own the land and depend
upon it for their livelihood are
directly concerned
the majority of the people of california
are not owners of the wildlands but are
dependent on the products from these
lands
these people as well as the landowners
benefit from good forest practices on
the timberlands
proper development of woodland grass and
brush areas for livestock and wildlife
and effective prevention and control of
fire insects and disease on all the
lands
most of all
protection and development of the
wildlands means more water for new homes
and cities and for new industries
more water to raise more food for the
citizens of the state and nation
full development of the wildlands means
more lumber more plywood more pulp and
other forest products
it means more beef and lamb for the
nation's tables
more wool for clothing
more of all animal products
and more opportunity for rest relaxation
and wholesome outdoor pleasure during
summer vacations and on weekend outings
it means continued enjoyment of
california's wildlife and recreational
communities that have few equals
anywhere in the nation
[Music]
thank you
so
[Applause]
thank you all
thanks everybody
thank you all for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you